on ne regarde pas le maire bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous dans
la matinale darty france on l'a vu
nouvelle manifestation nouvelle
répression de mort hier au soudan depuis
la chute du président omar el béchir
qu'est ce qui a changé
avait pas grand chose il ya eu un boum
octobre dernier ça fait quatre mois que
la situation peu rythmée par des parts
du sang en parler de 79 morts qui a été
le prétexte à la manifestation de diers
sur nous mais très poétiquement la
parade là pour l'amour
de la nation et donc citons quand on
sait que cette parade à qom bilan deux
morts supplémentaires donc on a 80 une
personne qui sont mortes depuis octobre
dernier on va pas vraiment beaucoup
d'évolutions sachant que le soudan est
un pays stratégique
il ya vraiment pas d'intérêt aujourd'hui
qu'il soit frappé d'instabilité parce
qu'il est ouvert sur un porto frontalier
de sept pays la libye le tchad la
centrafrique le soudan du sud l'egypte
l'ethiopie et fui l'erythrée alors on
l'a vu aussi il ya des dirigeants de la
société civile qui sont arrêtés pour
quelles raisons oui en fait il ya eu
dimanche dernier on a été moins med al
fekki bien avant
omer youssif avaient été arrêtés qui
était un ministre dont qui ont participé
à cette conseil de transition il faut
dire que les comités de résistance
aujourd'hui sont structurés de manière
assez sérieuse donc on va vers un
mouvement de déstabilisation du pays les
pellets la junte militaire au pouvoir
obligé de hausser le ton pour essayer
d'équilibrer un tout petit peu la
terreur dont je crois que l'arrestation
de ces personnalités et politiques et
civiles et est plutôt de nature à
dissuader ou à casser l'ampleur de la
mobilisation
non
ça ne fonctionne malheureusement pas
puisque là
la marche d'hier notamment avaient pour
l'être motif la libération de toutes ces
personnes qui sont arrêtés que ce soit
des militants de bave lamda non c'est
pas en train de fonctionner il ya plutôt
quelque chose de très sérieux au niveau
de la manière dont c'est fait les choses
sont organisées on a vu que tout un
émissaire de l'union africaine arrivée
le président de la commission mustafa
qui a fait le déplacement ce week-end
pour essayer de calmer le jeu il n'y a
pas de pluie les américains désormais
menace de ne s'en prendre à des
personnalités directement au niveau des
tensions puisque en sucrant l'aide de
700 millions et
notamment en mettant la pression sur la
banque mondiale pour qu'elle cesse tout
penaud vis-à-vis du soudan
décidément ça n'a pas produit beaucoup
d'effets donc la désormais on va aller
vers des des sanctions beaucoup plus
ciblées sur des sur des personnalités
oui oui pour pour quelles raisons les
militaires n'arrivent pas à s'entendre
avec avec les civils qui estrie non en
fait les élus le général al bouraq s'est
exprimé ce week end sur sudan tv le
radiodiffuseur public c'était la
première fois qu'il s'exprimait dans une
interview est ce qu'il dit clairement
c'est qu'il a la volonté de rendre le
pouvoir aux civils et alors qu'il ya pas
de leur part en tout cas d'après ses
déclarations une volonté de confisquer
le pouvoir la condition qui est posée
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faudrait qu'il y
ait un consensus au niveau civil pour
que on aille vers des élections et après
les élections l'armée promet de se
retirer donc la problématique qui se
pose aujourd'hui c'est l'absence de
consensus dégagé par les partis
d'opposition et une ayez la société
civile pour aller donc vers cette
transition tant espéré alors certains
disent aussi qu'il y à des personnalités
influentes sous le mandat de d'omar
el-béchir qui ont été réhabilités par
par les militaires c'est le cas ça a été
ça déjà de ce conseil de s'ouvre à elle
n'était pas composée de militaires il y
avait des personnalités
de l'ancien gouvernement le général vous
rend lui-même a travaillé avec omar el
béchir vous savez c'est assez difficile
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui au soudan
c'est un pays qui
a donc ses positions stratégiques parce
qu'il est ouvert en même temps sur l'eau
le le lama centre le centre de l'afrique
avec le tchad la centrafrique est reçue
l'est avec l'ethiopie donc les pays de
la corne et tout donc c'est vraiment
très complexe on peut pas laisser qui a
une situation qui implosent de ce côté
et alors qu'elle est calé quelle serait
la solution selon vous les élections en
2023 oui les élections se sont sont de
la solution mais surtout que la classe
politique puisse faire oeuvre utile se
mettre ensemble pour aller au delà de
petites divergences et poussés notamment
le poum le pouvoir militaire aujourd'hui
à tenir ses engagements qui sont entre
autres de rendre le pouvoir aux civils
dès que les élections soient organisées
pour finir quels sont les divergences
entre entre ces différents partis
d'opposition civile alors c'est celle
des divergences sont profondes pourquoi
parce que ce pays qui est resté pendant
longtemps l'ancien président omar
el-béchir el béchir est resté trente ans
au pouvoir ont des comptes ça des
structures un tout petit peu et donc
aujourd'hui il ya toute une culture
politique
voila voila et qui n'existe pas et tout
ça n'est pas de nature à accompagner
aujourd'hui la maturité des différents
acteurs vous avez vu là par exemple il
ya une initiative qui a été prise par
l'allemand volker perthes qui est
l'envoyé spécial du secrétaire général
des nations unies là-bas initiative qui
visait à dire bon allez on va maintenant
le tour de la table on essaie dé changer
sauf que c'est pas bien vu par la junte
militaire qui pensent que il pourrait
être un facilitateur mais pas
l'initiateur de démarches qui doivent
émaner d'abord d'acteurs politiques
locaux merci beaucoup morgan palmer pour
votre analyse ce matin dans la matinale
de témoin